speaking of Fox News two just pathetic
moments from last night that I want to
go over with you first and foremost As
Trump was getting ready to speak at
Bedminster after his second arrest
yesterday that is the speech in which
Trump admitted to many of the crimes
he's accused of having committed Brian
kilmead introduces Trump as the
President of the United States now I've
been there and I've defended generally
speaking referring to him as president
Donald Trump in the context of once
you've been president you keep that
title people introduce you know
President George W bush or whatever when
you have a live event and you say the
president of the United States will now
speak that is a different level
altogether listen to this insanity
days
and also the first time after being
indicted on federal charges okay I know
you get to keep the title president for
life but this is a live news event where
a reporter is tele reporter I use that
term loosely a guy on the camera is
telling the audience the president of
the United States will now speak it
would be useful to clarify we're talking
about former president Donald Trump if
this wasn't humiliating enough for Fox
news last night
Fox News also ended it's eight o'clock
Eastern hour with the lower third
wannabe dictator speaks at the White
House after having his political rival
arrested referring to
President Joe Biden the actual president
wannabe dictator speaks at the White
House after having his political rival
arrested of course they have still
presented no evidence whatsoever that
Joe Biden has had any even passing
involvement in this prosecution of
Donald Trump at neither the state nor
the federal level that was Fox news last
night
is this part of the ratings decline
I don't know or is this part of what's
keeping the ratings where they I really
don't know what to tell you but an
insane night on Fox News as insane as
Trump's day was Fox news's night and I
don't expect this stuff to change
anytime soon